[Music]
why would you need these kind of lines
in a galactic parking lot shouldn't it
just be a series of different sized
squares for vertical landing and takeoff
also what's the deal with these parking
lot lights they're illuminating a
building that's already lit up
and neglecting the rest of the parking
lot i mean it's different from the stuff
on earth
they have sex dolls on earth and
something tells me morty knows way too
much about that
aliens on another planet not only speak
perfect english but their stores have
open and closed signs written only in
english
like what if you passed away or died or
something i wouldn't even have anything
to remember
all the cool stuff we did you know
remembering your late grandfather every
time you use your sex robot
so we're just going to pretend this
isn't happening well not with that
attitude we aren't
rick why would you let morty bring that
thing into our house i mean we know
jerry has no power but why did beth
allow it in the house the real question
for rick is
why did you buy that for morty in the
first place really simply drinking from
the carton is a sin but it's doubled
when you're drinking from the carton
after having sex with an alien robot
sorry them's the rules intervening with
puberty you'll
turn him into ray fines and red dragon
first
it's clearly ralph fiennes i mean learn
to pronounce things
but also referencing ralph fiennis from
red dragon instead of tom noonan from
manhunter just a few seconds ago morty
was robo-railing so hard he had the
downstairs light swinging but these
knickknacks just stay put on his
headboard
i don't even know how these stay put
when he's not deep droiding this thing
could grow to the size of delaware
pretending like delaware is large
or exists i've gone too many episodes
without sending this and i can't hold
back anymore
that sock has never been moved from that
spot in the garage and it drives me
absolutely insane every time i see it
my therapist will be thankful i don't
have to discuss that with her anymore
portal question 253
if you can't see through the portal how
would this creature know exactly where
and how to grab summer
still think it's a good idea to go
through holes without a wiener wubble up
a dumb dub
sorry i just always wanted to do that so
maybe a sin on me
that's fair great now i have to take
over a whole planet because of your
stupid boobs
i can't tell if the show is aware and
poking fun at victim blaming or just
casually using it for a laugh and
considering the damage that kind of
thinking does every day this is either a
sin for the show's attitude or the
idiots who think this way
also watch what you're saying about
boobs mister those things are like
universally beloved
he goes tom hanks pizza then boobs
and honestly hanks and pizza better
watch their back why do tv families
always store their fruit so close to the
floor
also storing bananas with your other
fruit is a terrible idea bananas release
a gas that makes other fruit spoil
quicker
crap that was actually somewhat
educational um bananas look like penises
saved it your hands bears your hands
title of my sex play tape
hands oh you are going to ruin that kid
morty
could be worse he could be showing him
caillou what's the opposite of wubble up
a dub dubs am i right ladies and
gentlemen
it's bad enough you're breaking the
fourth wall but now you're throwing test
questions our way too
i'm tired of zoom classes leave me alone
having a section of a newspaper simply
titled
news spider in sector c is still alive
plan your route accordingly and expect
delays so this world's just going to be
a bunch of sexist jokes
now i mean admittedly super hilarious
sexist jokes like
that restaurant that's called just a
bite of yours
the weather report said is anyone else
cold or is it just me
sorry i mean um that's racist females
are placed into educational programs the
males
they get to play outside the original
plot outline for boss baby somehow makes
its way into this episode
yeah you know what i have to say about
that
rick survives this fart can we talk
about these ear
arms for a second we've seen them active
so we know they aren't just vestigial so
how does the musculature work part of
the reason you can control your arms is
in the shoulders and chest
and sure maybe they have some thick
traps hiding under that hair but what
about the pecs shouldn't they have some
sort of chest muscles where their cheeks
would be
and that would mean they would also have
boobs there too six arms should mean six
boobs damn it also do you know how hard
it would be to hold your arms up like
that all day those arms should be
dangling down like flaccid fleshy
earrings
also also does this mean if they don't
apply deodorant they have bo right next
to their nose
this is terrible design and the god of
this universe should be punished to the
maximum extent of celestial law
was this really the time to make that
point summer kids
this is for you daddy well i guess we
know where this episode stands on the
whole nature versus nurture debate
good news parents what you do doesn't
make a difference only handcuffing four
of the six arms and doing it via two
separate handcuff sets with a foot of
chain between them
and in front of the body this does
nothing
look at the tag read it where was that
tag hiding
and is that really where a tag would be
on a top like this mark
jacob these are names of the penis look
a lot of what these alien ladies are
saying about men is very true but we
give our penises
way more interesting names than mark or
jacob like boomerang or big rick or
count shlongula if you think my top is
cute
you cannot execute johnny cochraning
morty junior
smoking but where did he get the
cigarettes he hasn't gone outside no one
else in the house is a smoker
i don't want to masturbate i want to
conquer the planet oh just like this
generation and not be able to multitask
also this race is so horny they just
drop sex robots on them and then have
them all impregnated within minutes
so i think his murder boner would be
accompanied by a well
boner boner but first a deep sip from a
very tall glass of i told you so
those are gulps not sips you noisy and
biber
running wild running hot show makes fun
of motivating characters with songs and
that is just not acceptable without
survivor and robert pepper rocky would
have never been able to beat ivan drago
and don't you forget it also movie
steals the footloose scene from hot rod
hey
stop that thinking honking your horn
will stop an alien monster from
destroying your car and potentially
killing you
i never got that impression from reading
marmaduke well joe wants us to believe
that a kid in the 2010s would be reading
marmaduke
see you guys next week see everybody
next week this joke literally only works
one time the first time it airs unless
you're the kind of fan that plays your
blu-rays or streams weekly to be more
authentic
why don't you just prove you're a better
fan than the rest of us by having weekly
viewing parties where you can all quote
lines from the show and sing songs about
how great it is and
crap i just invented a religion didn't i
here it goes prego no doubt about it
wanna hang out with us on a live stream
we don't care if you're on the toilet in
your mom's basement or in the broom
closet just put on some deodorant and
join us during sin week 2021
march 22nd through 26th we'll release
three
extra sins videos and go live four times
to hang out with you all you have to do
is become a sin club member at
patreon.com
cinemasins do it now that way you're the
first to learn about our evil plans
and if you join today you have time to
watch over 70 exclusive videos and
podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd so we're
just going to pretend this isn't
happening
i'm not saying that's a bad idea just
asking i drive a dodge stratus
i think i hit puberty should i cut the
cord
i think it's linguine what you doing
we're dismantling
the most sophisticated sentient weapon
ever made
can't take this anymore i learned it by
watching you
i came here to do two things eat eggs
and
nothing and i'm not out of either